男性視聴者に向けて日本男者こいきろって
いう動画を作ったら結構反響が良かったの
で女性にどういう風に行きなさいみたいな
メッセージ力強いのをいただきたい
です男から見てたよいつ愛が発生するんや
その女に対するあれをね間違えたりいかん
のやまずどっかで出会う可愛かったり綺麗
だったりスタイルが良かったりいろんな面
でその女を気に入る一目惚れするわけやね
これは恋なんだ恋の目的というのはその女
を抱くことなんだだんだんその恋の期間が
長くなってきてある時その女を大一まそう
するとね途端に愛が発生するんや守ると
いうこと結局その女は自分のDNAを残し
てくれる人になるわけだから大事に守って
自分のDNAを残させんといかんねこれ
からが愛になるわけもう守らんといかん
やろ自分のためにから女はそういう風なん
だということがよく分かって変な要求し
たらあかんよね結婚式の時によう言う
じゃんこれで私もやっと幸せになりました
言って結婚することが幸せなんか違うよね
自分たちが生きる目的はここを間違えたら
いかんだ種族保存なんやそれを目的にして
人類がずっと単西胞から進化しながら40
万億年生命を引き継いできたわけやろだ
から我々になって自分のためだけに生き
たらいかんね後の人間ののために生きな
いかんねだから幸せになったというのは
その後の人間ができてそいつを育てて
トレーニングして1人前にしてそこまでで
自分の役目は終わりやねからそいつを
ちゃんと頭の中入れといてさ子供が1人前
になるようにするのが自分の役目だと思え
ばええわけだけどその前に子供作らない
かんはねその前に結婚せないかはねその前
に就職せないかよね家も立てないかそれを
ちゃんと1つずつこなして行けよと
いきなり愛してます好きだ言って金もない
のに結婚しちまうというそういうケースが
多いじゃんそいつはいか身勝手な行動に
なるねちゃんと努力しろと女の子1人
欲しくてその女の子に子供を産んでもらっ
て自分のDNAを残すんだと思えばその
順番を踏んできちっとやっていけちょ途中
から男向けのメッセージになってるん俺は
男向けになるわね
女の方はね本心本能というのは女に対して
そういうことを望んどるんだ何もお前を
幸福にするために俺がおるんじゃない
DNAを残すことが俺の幸福なんやから
その手をしろとそれが女に対する本心要求
なんだということが分かればえアメリカ
映画みたいにもベタベタベタベタ朝から
バンバで愛してるよ愛してるよという
あいつを要求してはあかんなんなものは
キリスト教徒が女の機嫌を取るためにやっ
とることやあれがレディファースだと思っ
とるなってないねま本心を知れとそれに
沿うように行動してやれば問題は起きない
男は自分のDNAを残そうとしとるのに
よそのDNAを残そうとするやつがおる
じゃん不倫だ浮気だでそりゃ怒るぞと自分
のDNAを残してもらうためにその女の子
を大事にしとるんだからよそえ行くなと男
の方も仏教のねあれ見てこら様が言っとん
のはジイていうやろジイとはね何にも
セックスをすることじゃないんやあれは
構わんのや自然なんだからところがよその
嫁さんと寝るなって言っとるんやそいつは
問題が起こるよとだけど独身の女なら構わ
んこっちも要する嫁さんじゃなけりゃ構わ
んということやろうねあれも女の方がよう
起こるけど
なあ最後にこのチャンネル見てくれてる
女性の方に何か一言メッセージをいただき
たいですそうですねやっぱり己れの本心を
知ってこらんそれは非常に難しいんやけど
みんな理性的に動くからいかんのよね特に
リベラルなんてなんかこう自分に都合の
いい理性を作るやろまず具体的な一歩とし
てどういうことをやったら良いとかあり
ますかやっぱりうちの用事分のあれを
見とるとね小さい頃に男と男の子ねああ
いうのとごっちゃまでの生活をしたらええ
な同じ仲間っていう遊び仲間でもええそれ
が小学校いっぱい続くとええよ男すごいね
と思っちゃううちでな幼稚園から大体
始める早いやつは0歳から始めるんやけど
なで男と女ごっちゃにしとくとね小学校の
23年になるとな男の子は筋肉がついて
くるんやそうすと練習が終わった後な
みんなウエットスーツを脱いでないこんな
格好値であれ真似するんよこ見るのそれを
ね乳幼児はね羨ましそうな顔してみるんや
で女はなミフりをするんだいやね男ってて
言いながらなこうやってしっかり見とるよ
あれでええんじゃね本身そのまま出せば
ええ幼少期過ぎてる10代20代30代の
女性だとどうですかね手遅れもうちゃんと
した女にはなれんよね文句しに文句言って
あんたらのおかげで私はちゃんとした女に
ならんやた言え手遅れになった女性なりに
何かできることてますかね大変なことよね
だ自分の本能を知るのは仏教の仕事内考案
というのがあるやろ丸とは何かって言って
それの答えを出す本能で答えを出さんと
いかんのよそれが非常に難しいのね
あるいは神社の場合は巫女が狂乱状態に
なって踊り狂ったりして答えを出してくる
やろあれリセを殺しとる姿ないあるいは酒
飲んだらええじゃん酒飲むと理性から消え
てくやろエのアルコール本能が出てくるや
ん自分の本能を知ればるねよ酒飲んで喧嘩
しとるわな本能同士は喧嘩するんだそう
やって自分の本能を知るできるだけ一生
懸命自分の本能を隠すからいかんのよ本心
をうまくいかんよ
[音楽]
ねDET